今日はのも皆様に
犬たちの素晴らしい力を
お話でいければと思います
私はこの街で生まれました
50年音楽をやっておりもスプール家です
40年前にベッドのヘッドクォーターのあるニューヨーク永住いたしました
らいふわぁって
セラピートップたちの育成をて受ける
ます
私は言葉がしゃべれないことでした友利です
知っているという
重症でした
母親を呼べませんおかあさんを呼べないことでした
当然戦後すぐですから
もちろん1女でありますしかし私はこれを犬たちの力を借りて
音楽の力を借りて私は
いました
ば分今日も最後まで使えず行けると思います
我が家の愛犬に造られました
人は私の言葉を待ってくれません
しかし犬たちは私を待ってくれました
鳥羽の回復生きる勇気を得ました
そしてアメリカへ渡ります a セラピーと婦たちの育成を40年目になりました
人間たちの最愛のパートナーだと思います
このを私たち人間が抱える大きな病
特に心の病をこのいるたちが作ってくれます
命も救ってくれます私が商品だと思っております
そして
このセラピードッグはアメリカで65年ほど前に生まれました
動物買い材料
アニマル足セットセラピーです
多くの皆さんが今病院や施設でいるたちと力を帰っています
そしてこの中央日本橋も4000名の要介護の必要な高齢者を言えばケアしています
ディジョンおばあちゃんです
さあそのいるたちが
どんなところで活性ですよ高齢者の場所ます
障害者の施設へ行きます元の延命に使います
そして
教育の現場に入ります
もう一つはアメリカで長く
歴史のあるゲーム所の服役囚の社会福利に使います
そして日本では一つだけ大きな出来事がありました
東日本の震災です
なあ年前にこの地 b セラピー独行設定入りました
そしてそこで犬たちにもあります
被曝です
私のセラピードッグはすべてが捨て犬です
日本は大きなさっ処分があります当時は65万等の最初
がして殺しますいる猫です
73年に動物愛護法をつくりまし
しかしクリはこれを守れません
いるたち猫達がガスの中で弄っちゃう
その子たちをつくって2年間教育します
そしてセラピーとっくに生まれ変わることができる
震災地でも被曝をした子たちこの子たちを救い
同じようにセラピー徳利育成することができました
一般に生きていれば私たち人間を作ってくれる大きな役割を示してくれますそれでは
スライドみてください
この東京日本橋のおじいちゃんですアルツハイマーです
これが最初の日本で生まれた最初の名犬チロリおい
ラピード第1号であります
r ちゃいま
記憶の回復
この子の名前を呼ぶことを覚えることで家族の名前を思い出します
ここ
一緒に歩きたいという気持ちが
患者を奮い立たせます
そして排便排尿を自分の足でトイレに行く
これを犬が誘導します
そして一緒に過ごして絆を深めます
要介護5のこのオーディションは
あ物ハイマー
とんどの起動止まりましたしかしこのちろりという優秀なスペインのセラピードックに
あったことで4年1
治療を続けます
歩く夏子と笑顔海は家族の名前も思い出すことができました
大きな症例だと思いますさあこの
セラピードッグたちはいい
ステイルです masa
日本の
動物愛護という法律の中でどれだけのいるタチネコたちが苦しんでガスの中で死んで
いくか見てください
千葉くるんですっ
はストナンバーワンです当時2万投稿しました
この子たちはすべてしているです家族がありましたしてられます
7日間繋留されて
そしてその次のない日は翌日に
ガスてこうします
みんな家族がいたはずですしてられた子達です
1日間の
渓流がある
一つ取得家が分かれます
俺一瓶の部屋だし
追い込まれますそしてガス室に入ります
おりテレビカメラを始めていました
国はこれ反対しました
なぜですか
それを見せることは
ダメだと思いました
しかしプレイネジで入りました
このことによって
色等猫達がどのようにしてられてこうされていくかということがあっ
屋さん知ることができました
この子達をつくってセラピードッグに生まれ変わらせます
教育を受ければ必ず立派になりました
ガスしていまし
アメリカのみなさん私に言いましたあなたの国は
犬猫のアウシュビッツがあるという
どんな日中7や g 2 welly で経済大国になっても私たちはこのことが
変わらなければ
日本人を認めないと言われました
これは充実した
私は70年代後半から公園に来るたび日本中の保険上もありません
大変な
バス室での耳目の姿がありました
ラスです
以前はガス後描画古墳二酸化炭素
興奮では心拍停止ない子がたくさんいます
俺弘中入れました
あってはなりません
今ガスの治療が増えましたほとんどと思います
この子たちの姿を見てください
雑誌思うんですよく安楽死ということがあります
これはありません
悲鳴と恐怖とその中で
なくなっています
これが日本のペット産業の最後ますし
ベッド作業は1兆5000億の売上をあげました
その陰で混ぜ子の命を殺すんですよ
そんなお金がほしいですか
これなんでしょう
上手くなった子たちが火の中に入った骨分です
今の姿になるためにこの子たちは生まれてきたわけではありません
しかししてる
当時は私の時代65万今
時代が変わりましたみんながこのことに注目してくれます
しかしまだ10万頭少し入ると猫達がまだ
出す筆や
これ変えましょう
さあ
このことが帰らなければ
私はこの日本の経済大国の中で胸を張って
世界に
実感ことができないところでしょう
4後パンのこれが問題だし
小さいです
7年前
癒し日本の震災入りました
大変厳しい震災でしたセラピートッポ連れて残された
高齢者や障害者のもとへ入ります
この子たちは全部スペインのセラピー怒りっぱに被災地で
被災者を助けます
夢中で助けます
さあ福島に入りました
福島で
被災した員たちに出会いますし
福島と別でした
被曝です
犬たちが被曝をします
家畜も被爆しましたさあ
一時避難がありましたゆたち家畜おいてきましたね
置いてきぼりです
帰れなくなります
この子たちはバックをして苦しみます
そして
[ __ ]されて最初分
この子福島いわきです
あっち加熱ところです
犬た人姿ではありません
だこれ救出しますそして
命をすって
2年半供給します
今が姿見てください
ふとつけました
いい男になりました
今立派に活躍してます服は今この中国日本橋の
多くの高齢者の下で活躍した
お子
厳しい障害を持つになったカパのリハビリに服が寄り添って誘導します
歩けなかった方が吹くと一緒に今
ロービーをを収録シュートもあるようになります
免疫を上げていきます一緒に頑張る
大きな役割を務めていきます
さあどんどんの子が被曝をしました福島です
除染します
被曝は移ることはありません
そしてこの子たちをもう一度教育します
近時ぴん子という名前をつけましたえっ
現地です今活躍してます
立派に教育を受け
多くの障害者と
高齢者のか妖怪も頃おばあちゃんたち言いますくっています
銀次の活躍でし
牛場の子達です
[音楽]
多くの子がまだ残されています
最後までつくらなければなりません皆さん東日本はもう
7年経ちました
しかしまだ
厳しい状況がたくさんついてます
家族か別れて津波の中助かったインターしです
家族は震災で命を落としました
その家族が残した唯一の
犬たちで子達
国はこれをお越します
言葉が変わりますオカクリな
その後に税所くんがなぜ助けたんですか
なぜ助けるんですか
そう殺すんですかあってはなりません
この子達です今は立派にセラピー得になります
命があればこの子達は
立派になるはずです
教育ですし
私の4の日雪泥
456教科書を学びます
そして落ち心で強いません
みんなしているたちです
被災したいう性質です
生命ビルでした
明日の朝貸す人に入ることです
なぜこの子たちが人を助ける役目をできる
多分
痛みを知っているからだと思います
夢中5分人を助けます
犬たちの健気さ愛情がブレない
そして強い信頼性を持って生まれ変わった
俺がセラピードックろ世界です
[音楽]
その子達を連れて俺福島の相馬です
仮設住宅の皆さんに訪問します福島で生まれた子ですから今
立派なセラピートップがたくさん貼られますこの子達をすべて
訪問活動します
被災者の皆さんです
被災地は今もティッシュ
や37年としました
もう
ものではありません
幌に追い込まれた皆さんが自死をする
これなぜ助けられないんですか
you たちは夢中でそう支えていきます
大門活動してっ
広島のおばあちゃんです
この子は福島でを救出した
被爆そして
所属を全部しないました新しい名前付けました
広まると名前付けました
日の丸今立派なシェア p トップになって
ちょっとがいるしました
牛場便がわかりますから
福島のおばあちゃんが福島弁で話すと大変喜びます
牛場の犬たちがんセラピートップになっ
一番の皆さんもう一度作っ
その活動をこの子達は
しています
私はこの子達を育てて
ここにがありますしみんな立派です
家を前にしてそして助けられた子たちが私たち人間を救いまし
私も
最初で話してい
いるに造られました
やっぱり立てるのも愛犬の刷毛です
you たちの力そしてプレない愛情そして今読んだかなセラピードックを必要とする
時代になりました
大きな病院もこのことを必要になりました
だとしたんじゃ
ソシオこれやめましょ
これあってはなりませんそして
4から尺を分なくしましょうそして東京はオリンピックが
開催されてそのオリンピックをする国がガス室を開いてベッドのいるたち猫達を殺すん
ですか
難しいですね
これあってはならないと思います
このことを変えなければならそして私たちに中は胸を張って動物愛護口になって世界の
皆さんとお会いするべきだと私は思います
最後に
ちろりという捨て犬が私に残してくれた
どこかもしれません
どうぞ女しました
築地川銀座公園するそうです
どうぞ立っています
迷宮んでした
今年暮れに
色年ですから
獣害めいけんの
銅像が選ばないその3位にチロちゃんが選ばれました
市は私の友人がへ開けたたの需要です
置いてきぼりになりましたね
ちろりは
堂々
歳になりました
渋谷のハチ公が恋でした
渋谷のハチ公を抑えることができました
命剣でした
後ろ足を引きずり2耳が垂れて
そして
なごみの中に捨てられたことです
それが私と十数年多くの高齢者障害者を助けてきました
誇れるプです
立派な子でした
最後にチロちゃんが私に残した言葉です
小さな命を救えない国は
人を救うことができません
そして
あのさっ処分の現場の中に入ると
命あるものは幸せになる権利があります
命あるものは幸せになる権利があるんですその権利を取るとは
奪い取ることがあってはなりません
犬達のお話をさせていただきましたありがとうございました
[拍手]